in this episode of cloudy I adventures
find out how to use tensor board to
visualize your model and debug problems
debugging problems is a lot easier when
you can see what the problem is but with
gigs of training data feeding into a
complex model that can get complicated
thankfully tester board makes this a lot
easier unlike traditional programming
machine learning can be very
unpredictable the quality of your data
along with the nuances of your model
including the many parameters that must
be chosen all have wide-ranging
influences on the success or failure of
the training process if only there was
some way to track some of these metrics
through the training process and also
look at the structure of the model that
we created that would enable us to tune
the model and debug problems that we see
now this abstract process can be
difficult to visualize but luckily
tensorflow has a built-in solution meet
tensor board tensor flows built-in
visualizer which enables you to do a
wide range of things from seeing your
model structure to watching your
training progress tensor flow uses the
idea of computational graphs under the
hood this means that instead of adding
two numbers in the traditional sense it
constructs an add operator and passes in
as inputs the values being added
together so when we think about tensor
flow training your model it's really
executing everything as part of its
graph tensor board can visualize these
models so you can see what they look
like and more importantly ensure that
you've wired all the pieces up the way
you want it to here's an example of a
more complex version of a model graph
being visualized by tensor flow notice
how tensor flow allows us to zoom pan
and expand elements to see more details
this means that we can look at the model
at different layers of abstraction which
can help reduce the visual complexity
moreover tensor board does more than
just show the model structure it can
also plot the progression of metrics on
a nice graph typically we might plot
things like accuracy loss across entropy
and depending on the model different
metrics can be important for you and
tensor flows canned estimators they come
with a set of values pre-configured to
be shown in tensor board so that serves
as a great starting point
tensor board can display also a wide
variety of other information including
histograms distributions embeddings
as well as the audio pictures and text
data that goes with your model but that
parts for a future video for now let's
take a look at an example of 10 support
with the linear model that we've been
using so far first we'll start tensor
board and point it to the directory
where our model structure and checkpoint
files are saved this will start a local
server on point port 6 0 0 6 yes that
spells out goog we can see here some of
the scalar metrics that are provided by
default with the linear classifier we
can also expand and zoom into any of
these graphs double-clicking allows us
to zoom back up you can see our train
progressed nicely with a decreasing loss
over time it's also clear that the
training has been entirely completed as
the loss is still decreasing at a nice
rate even at the end of training so this
might clue us in that perhaps we could
run the training process a bit longer
and get the most out of this training
process let's go over to graphs tab now
notice that on the surface the graph is
pretty simple we're able to expand each
of these blocks by clicking the plus
sign to see more detail for example if I
expand the linear block we see that it's
made up of a number of sub components
and we can scroll to zoom in and out as
well as click and drag to pan and see
other parts of the graph notice also
that the names we gave our future
columns like flower features show up as
named graph components this can help
with debugging and identifying how the
graph is all hooked up
most of tester flows operations can be
named so that's a great way to clarify
your models and see what's going on
today we learned that machine learning
is much easier and more fun when you can
visualize the model along with important
metrics tensor board allows you to do
this with ease and better yet it's built
into tensor flow I'm Yu Feng Guo and
thanks for watching this episode of
cloudy adventures and remember next time
you need to visualize your machine
learning use tensor board to see what's
happening under the hood
if you want more machine learning
actions be sure to subscribe to the
channel to catch future episodes as they
come out also the creators of tensor
boards gave this excellent talk that the
tensorflow dev summit earlier this year
check it out for a more in-depth look at
this
[Music]